[Music]
the european parliament welcomes the 750
billion euro covid 19 recovery fund
agreed by eu leaders
but says it must not come at the cost of
the eu's long-term budget priorities
i'm not happy about the deal
we think that it is not giving proper
answers to the challenges of the next
seven years
it has to be more future orientated
to ensure a sustainable long-term
recovery parliament says investment in
the green deal
the digital economy erasmus health and
research
must be safeguarded it says cuts to
flagship eu programs
are unacceptable
insist that parliament will not give its
consent without an agreement on the
introduction of new
eu revenue sources such as a levy on
non-recycled plastic waste
or on co2 emissions which would help
cover the cost of the recovery plan
the european parliament is also
concerned that eu leaders weakened
efforts to include protections to the
rule of law by limiting eu funding to
countries failing to uphold media
freedoms and human rights
parliament wants negotiations to
conclude by the end of october
for a smooth start to eu programmes from
[Music]
2021